oh you know what I heard dude I [ __ ]
Nick can in the mornings they're talking
about this
I listen Academy my Sunday when I Drive
them to school so I hear Nick in the
morning hopefully don't get fired from
that but uh they were talking about the
celebrities that make the most money
with their Instagram swipe ups or a post
you know what you know who's the highest
who gets paid most of post on Instagram
the rock you how much he gets paid
proposed Brian oh god damn it it's gonna
hurt my feelings it's kind of hurt my
feelings what do we got 1.15 million
dollars per post what are you talking
about god damn it he makes money he is
undeniable now he is young all the
steroids are just a couple because I
don't know but I'd like to know his
doctor cuz I would meet him
I don't want to be that jackpot love to
get ready here's the thing he looked we
couldn't look better I was so happy with
his thickness in ballers but you know
when you do it for that long the problem
is you're you get older it makes you it
ages you will your skin your skin can
only hang tight for so long your skin
gets funnier dear Papa when your
mother's near papi it looks like it's
like using nitrous on your collar all
the [ __ ] time
you don't think the rock makes a million
bucks to post some stupid thing on
Instagram you know me has more money
than God
you don't think has an entire staff
monitoring his blood cell canal
it's [ __ ] cholesterol his blood
pressure how much keep your take what
movie should eat that dude I bet is a
[ __ ] machine he probably is but he
still looks like he's taking a lot of
running gear she's still running gear
that's mine looks great though he's got
veins besides my index finger running
through his entire body missile kind of
I'll tell you right now if our boy Todd
Feldman called me and said hey brethren
listen I was talking to Jerry
Bruckheimer they're having him direct a
new Batman we want you to be Batman but
you got to gain 30 pounds of muscle and
here's a number I would call that number
before I even hung up the phone you'd be
so excited to go on - just for once to
get straight
- so who's your OB picture me like this
with my dick root out all the time yep
and you lose your little pod so you
could wear like pants shorts they were
low and have hip muscles but hip muscles
for the first time did you say ponch
yeah you got some nerve what turkey
gobbler neck what'd I say huh no you
know you know you know you got a little
blood you're a little soft in the middle
that's a little soft in the minute I
haven't earned it
well that's your one that's your one
Achilles heel
honey time here's the thing now when
Papa gets stressed out or I can't go
into studio and I get depressed cuz
these zooms suck my [ __ ] right when I
get sad what I like to do I'd like to
eat I don't do drugs I don't drink I
like to eat I'm not making this up I've
ordered two large pepperoni extra
pepperoni extra sauce pizzas from
Domino's for seven nights in a row and
you you need to both of those I don't
need both of them I like an idea I'll
need a whole one myself in the meantime
and now Tiger show you some your own
pizza what mean he'll be let me figure
it out and he'll go [ __ ] cute he
looks and goes Papa I think we need a
fresh pizza oh dude what he goes I need
some fresh boots I'm like I think you're
right but I tell you this right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]